[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
journalist for the financial times
jasmine cameron chuleshi and the
columnist for the article ali mirage
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the telegraph
has the headline a bruise for every day
of lockdown referring to the case of
six-year-old arthur labino-hughes who
was systematically abused by his father
and his father's partner before his
death
the son leads with the same did they
learn nothing from baby p a child
cruelty case from 2007.
the eye hears there are concerns too
many people have deleted the nhs covid
app making it more difficult to track
cases of the omicron variant
the mirror leads with a message to the
conservative party about festive parties
with the headline make your mind up on
christmas
the metro understands 152 people will
fined 200 pounds each for not wearing
masks on public transport in london on
the first day of titan rules on tuesday
the guardian reports labor's biggest
funder and union backer unite will cut
its political donations to the party
and according to the financial times the
u.s government has managed to convince
its saudi counterparts to keep
increasing monthly crude oil production
joining me tonight jasmine cameron
chaleshi and ali mirage they both are
good evening to you both um let's start
with the metro and that story of uh
people being uh obliged to wear masks on
the underground or on transport that
being brought into force ali
well i think this is a a serious move uh
to enforce the rules the government
announced earlier this week
from a vote in parliament that they were
actually going to introduce or
reintroduce the wearing of face masks
for public transport and in retail uh
settings uh which i think is actually a
very sensible and measured thing to do
and if the government's learned one
thing over the last uh since last march
when we first encountered this uh
vile um disease
uh we basically have to take precautions
and take them early so i think it's
perfectly sensible and i have seen
people on the tube generally
beginning to comply with this but there
are stuff some people who still refuse
to and i think it's right and i've just
come back from
zurich at the weekend and berlin a
couple of weeks before that and i can
tell you that in europe in these cities
in europe they are much more draconian
than we are in enforcing these things uh
particularly coveted vaccination
passports as well in every single uh
restaurant or bar you go to in both of
those cities you have to prove your
vaccination status and also proof of
identification as well so we have been
quite
relaxed in some cases here and this
measure does not seem draconian to me i
think it's perfectly justified yes and
that relaxed nature that ali is talking
about jasmine is a born out by uh
figures from tfl there were 5 101
interventions on public transport today
for people obviously not wearing masks
yeah i mean the figures are very
encouraging because it does show it's
not just a case of introducing rules
there seems to be some you know sense of
enforcing them and anecdotally i would
say that i've seen more and more people
wearing masks i mean
with transport for london it's been the
rules for actually quite a long time
that you do have to be massed up but not
many people really have been following
them and it would be it wasn't uncommon
to see people not wearing face coverings
but since the change in rules we are
seeing that you know people are wearing
masks more often there is a sense that
actually this is one of the many steps
we need to take to hopefully prevent
further restrictions coming into place
and do you think it will continue people
will continue or begin to to comply more
now
ali
i think so jillian i hope so look i
think we all have a role to play here uh
in this it's a collective effort the
government sets the rules uh certainly i
think jasmine is absolutely right that
those rules should then be enforced but
the government also has to strike that
balance and get the balance right
between treating people uh with respect
and dignity and allowing people to make
their own decisions about things and
also taking the necessary precautions at
the appropriate times the government at
all costs does not want to impose uh
further measures if if it can at all
avoid it but you also have to remember
the fact that there is serious economic
uh distress in the country we're doing
quite well economically on the back of
um a bounce back you know our economy is
growing quite strongly now but we still
have 2 trillion of public debt 400 400
um
billion of borrowing on the back of
cobin i can tell you that when it comes
to hospitality industry and all this
talk about whether we're going to be
having christmas parties or not i was
talking to my
hair stylist today in the city of london
and for some of those viewers you might
think that that's um uh might be amusing
that i have a hairstylist i do say i
didn't like to say ellie but well
you didn't know well i'm afraid i'm
afraid you need to be careful that could
be construed as baldist
but um look the point the point is that
he was telling me that uh after the
restrictions were lifted in july um even
now on mondays and fridays in the city
of london hardly any football at all and
on the other three days uh he's actually
been been seeing numbers go up but
between the the announcement of this
omicron variant and now in the space of
a week his takings have gone down a
thousand pounds so this is what we're
facing here so we all have a
responsibility to do all we can wearing
face master is not difficult taking a
pcr test on day two uh when you come
back from abroad is also uh not
difficult and if we stick to the rules
hopefully uh we'll try and control this
new variant and we won't have to have
further restrictions let's turn to the
eye jasmine and now more than ever with
this new omicron variant the contact
tracing app
is really
necessary but uh seemingly
the use of it has uh dropped away
yeah so i thought it was a really
interesting story so the papers looked
at some of the nhs stats and it shows
that use of the app is actually down now
it was part of the government rules that
all venues had to sort of display the
check-in code so people had an incentive
to download the app and to check in and
it was actually a really big part of our
public health strategy but it seems that
while the government are encouraging
people to use it naturally yusuf's use
of the app has dropped off and one thing
that is quite striking it'll be
interesting to see whether the
government starts to encourage people to
download the app again because we know
with this new variant one of the things
they're concerned about is community
transmission and they are concerned
about the number of cases and you know
making sure that these cases were
tracked so this app could potentially be
another you know tool that we could use
to control the spread but i think at the
moment the government is really trying
to take a light touch approach it's not
trying to be too draconian it's trying
to
get as many boosters and people as
possible and just trying to enforce mask
wearing and is hoping that the data on
the new variant shows that the current
vaccines we have work and that we won't
need to enforce any more restrictions
uh ali do you think that the government
might um
get more heavy-handed on people's use of
the tracing app that might be something
that they look to in the future
well potentially uh jillian and i think
there have been real problems uh over
the summer in particular before the
lockdown was lifted on this uh well
actually after the lockdown was lifted
on this pandemic issue with people
getting pinged all the time and i've
been pinged uh twice in the last couple
of weeks and it is irritating but the
good thing about uh being pinged in the
sense is that if you do sign up for a
pcr test the results do come out quite
quickly so it seems to be fairly easy to
go and get a test at least when i when i
booked one it wasn't very far from my
house it was quite easy and then you got
the result the next morning which was
good because the last thing you want to
be doing when you're trying to get the
economy uh up and running again and
bouncing back is for people to be back
at home indefinitely waiting for test
results so it is annoying but i just
think we have to face reality here none
of us like curbs on our freedoms we're a
free society we're used to moving around
at will and doing what we wish however
we also have to recognize that we're in
a collective effort against a
a a virus that mutates that constantly
poses new challenges to us that
continues to surprise us in many ways
now we all hope that this omicron
variant is not potent
and is not going to mutate and cause all
sorts of habit but it's too early to
tell so whilst we're in this uh
discovery phase if you like we need to
be careful we also know that a lot of
the projections from the scientists are
often wrong but it's better to be
cautious at this stage uh than to take
um liberties that we should be you know
careful of when we then have to impose
harder lockdowns potentially later which
no one wants yes a lot still to be
discovered about omicron to the guardian
uh then jasmine and good news about the
booster jab
yes this is actually a really
encouraging story so essentially the
guardian's reporting that covered
booster shots can dramatically increase
the body's immune defenses
and it's basically just reinforcing you
know what we already knew that getting
the booster job is a good idea and it
touches on the fact that you know the
nhs is preparing to administer booster
jobs and there are still lots of
questions about the logistics of that so
we know that the nhs at the moment is
trying to get through those waiting
lists they're under huge strains and
pressure at the moment and then at the
same time they're going to have to lead
the way to administer these booster jabs
and so boris johnson his press
conference earlier this week he tried to
outline a bit more detail and give the
public a bit more reassurances about how
this would work
but there's still a lot of uncertainties
but the roots the study is encouraging
and it does show that you know
ultimately getting booster job is
something that is beneficial to all of
us have a look at uh the telegraph um
and uh
this story over well fears about uh
privacy laws uh we have people quoted
here um
john whittingdale apparently led a
chorus of outrage over the court of
appeal ruling
that prevented the duchess's credibility
from being tested at trial this is about
the the privacy laws as they are at the
moment and being formed
jasmine
yeah so i mean this is part of the
ongoing dispute between meghan markle
and um the mail on sunday it's not while
she described um the victory as
precedent setting it's important to note
that no real laws have actually been
changed as a result and newspapers will
still be able to publish private
correspondence so long as they can prove
that they have a
public interest in doing so but i think
it does speak to the shifting
power dynamics between public figures
and the media it's no longer the case
where public figures sort of feel as
though they're not able to challenge or
bring up legal action against papers and
there is a sense with social media
especially that public figures are less
reliant on the media and newspapers to
sort of
position themselves to the public and so
i do think it's a it's an interesting
case and it's one of those where if you
were already a fan of meghan markle you
think it's an example of how um she's
been mistreated by the press and it sort
of vindicates her position if you didn't
like meghan markle you know you're not
going to be pleased with the outcome but
i do think the sort of calls surrounding
um freedom of speech and privacy laws so
do you think that's slightly overblown
ultimately nothing's essentially changed
but they've just ruled in her favor and
said that you know the letter shouldn't
have really been published
and this could go on ali the mail on
sunday considering going to the supreme
court
i think that's right and i think the
mail on sunday certainly is seeing it as
a battle between
privacy of the individual on the one
hand
and freedom of the press on the other
look this uh
letter was written by meghan markle to
her father thomas markle which was then
leaked or provided to the mail on sunday
and i think meghan markle has also come
under some criticism herself for
forgetting supposedly that uh one of her
former press officers cooperated with a
book uh about her and prince harry which
was earlier denied so i think there are
some issues there that people are asking
about but fundamentally it does come to
down to a question of press freedom and
whether public figures are
uh subject to a free-for-all we all
remember the phone hacking scandal that
was something that clearly should have
never happened and was outrageous is
that is this in the same league as that
probably not but it it's certainly
something that the mail on sunday wants
to see tested in the supreme court and
there is a feeling that parliament
has not been part of this discussion at
all which is why john whittingdale the
former culture secretary is leading a
chorus of objections to this that it
should really be not just the courts
making these decisions but also
parliament involved in certain uh senior
legal figures saying that the there
should be a new bill of rights to kind
of look at the uh the current human
rights act that we have which is based
on the european convention on human
rights so some legal questions to be
looked at in due course arising from
this trial as well